hey calm down this is coffee sometimes i
need it when a movie
bores me to sleep
[Music]
so mulan is disney's newest attempt to
take an animation
from their library and bleed all the
soul joy and life out of it and give us
a live-action adaptation of it and it
being disney's live-action adaptation of
disney's animated mulan is very much the
same story
just like the lion king in more than a
couple of ways mulan's the daughter of a
house
her father has no sons and then a man
from every house needs to get drafted to
fight in this war because war is now
in fact upon them so it falls to milan's
dad who has a lamp he's
clearly gonna get wasted in like two
seconds in war so she's like i'm gonna
pose as a dude
and enter the army which that'll cause a
lot of problems for her
and her house her family all of it but
she does it because that's what heroes
do and enter a much less enjoyable
version of mulan this is one of those
movies
if you see people out there reviewing
this movie they're like well the visuals
are great and it did for some of it some
of the scenery was great like some of
the fighting well i mean at the end of
the movie which is
otherwise i call the part where [ __ ]
actually starts to happen point is it
was entertaining and the scenery looked
great
when you couldn't tell that it was a
green screen and or cgi
as soon as you could you killed it i was
like man among your
five-month hiatus did you not have the
time to finish the cga okay it happens a
lot granted a lot of movies have a lot
of green screen and cgi but the trick is
did not let the audience know it but
really the problem is the supporting
characters the charm the charisma of
the general interactions with the
characters getting right to it eddie
murphy's character in the animated mulan
the little dragon he's not in it i mean
well
there's not a dragon there's a phoenix
that kind of
vaguely shows up once in a while to kind
of fly in the general direction she
needs to go so yes they took this
character from the animation that
interjected this fun vigor this
life this humor this vibrance into the
movie and they turn that character
into a phoenix waypoint from a video
game
that vaguely flies in a general
direction once in a while never talks
just does
that that's it i mean i don't know what
term
that is the opposite of brilliant i want
to use in this situation
um dumb as [ __ ] is the one i'm leaning
to currently it just wasn't smart i'm
not saying
i'm not directly comparing to the genie
in aladdin because
robin williams as the genie in aladdin
is top tier
godhood but it kind of felt like doing
aladdin without the genie eddie murphy
his character brought something to the
mulan animation if i look
back on that movie it's not 100 but
there is a large
portion of the charm and energy and
enjoyment i have in that movie comes
from that character somehow
also the original animation being about
a half an hour shorter had much better
time management like i said
generally the same stuff happens in the
live-action movie
as the animation just the live-action
movie is a half an hour longer which
means they're just drawing it out you
just
you're sitting there going look you're
just inflating the run time
i can feel it even for the villains oh
well this is kind of spoilerish
territory but keep this in mind
i just dropped 30 bucks to be bored out
of my skull
so i kind of don't care if you care i
understand this is where you
kind of dip out of this video and you
peace out but if you don't care great we
cannot care together and here's what i
have to say about the villains
that's right there are two villains in
this movie you have the villain from the
mulan animation
who should be main villain then you have
the actual villain in this live-action
version which you know the main villains
hawk well that hawk is a witch lady so
lady hawk
is this really mean witch lady and she
is to a point until she's i guess not
anymore because
i don't know she likes mulan they
concentrated on this new villain
so much and it seemed like the only
reason they did
is to have her give mulan that you go
girl moment and so mulan's like you're
right i'm not going to live this line so
she sheds her armor and she goes out to
battle and she basically blows the
whistle on herself which just
logistically speaking
that's just not smart it isn't and i get
it you want to send a message to 2020
don't hide who you are you know be
yourself
i know but you have to have it make
sense for the story and the characters
and it just didn't plus i think the way
the animated version did it had a lesson
in and of itself no matter what lie
you're living eventually it will come to
the surface that's pretty important
good things to know lessons taught
lessons received so then in the end evil
lady hawk
is like hey by the way i'm going to take
an arrow from mulan because
she listened to my girl power speech and
you know i like her now and by the time
it's like all right show down with this
guy you're just like
i don't even know who you are nor do you
care
granted i know that there are mulan
stories that predate the disney mulan
story so i don't know if those stories
have a witch lady but it's not whether
or not you have two villains it's
whether or not
you have balance in your antagonist and
this movie just
didn't find balance i mean the villain
in the animated mulan he doesn't stand
out in terms of personality as much as
some of the other disney villains do but
he was still menacing as hell and he did
stand out
as the villain if you're gonna do that
you gotta make it better in fact if
you're gonna make a live animation you
have to justify
its existence at all and in the end this
movie just it didn't
basically disney does exactly what you
think disney would do
for the live action mulan it's as simple
as i can put it i mean a live action
mulan actually does
lend itself to them doing some pretty
great things
but it's so similar to the animation
with nothing that made the animation
endearing charming generally enjoyable
i'm sure someone's gonna like pass it
off as like well it's
darker it's not really darker it's just
more boring i mean animated mulan was
pretty dark the scene where those two
messengers are running away and big bad
guys like
how many does it take to send a message
and one dude just draws his arrow and it
goes black
they're like oh oh wow something about
the implication
this movie doesn't have any of that
bringing up another point that the
animation did better than you know that
scene where they're all like it's it's a
musical number and they're in the snow
and then also the ho when they come
across this burn town and things just
destroyed the sudden stop
change shift in energy that was really
impactful it was very
effectively done this movie they just
kind of stroll up onto it and oh yeah
those are burnt towns what happens in
war it's just one example yeah but
it's one example that's fresh in my mind
that illustrates the point that
the live-action movies not just mulan
but some of the other ones they're going
through the motions
but they're not really doing it as well
as the animated original disney is and
mulan proves that disney's the cover of
that fat boy slim album one thing that
embodies the entire mindset of disney
itself
it's that mulan actually it's the nail
in the coffin at this point between
lion king and mulan i now actively do
not look forward to disney live-action
adaptations
of their animations there's a timer i
was like all right these are pretty good
not anymore the animations at this point
remain
far superior and i'm not going to
remember this movie in t-minus one day
yep already forgot you're welcome for
the 30 bucks dicks
all right so mulan the live-action
version did you spend
30 extra bucks on top of your disney
plus subscription to watch it or were
you just
waiting for some dumb [ __ ] like me to
do it it's all right i understand this
is what i do after all i knew i was
going to take this app
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you